what's the next elimination what's the
next one biggest challenge
shot bigger than johnny simms oh my god
oh god all right let's look at the
nominees for this one
all right we got oh i love that i love
the difference in the pictures here
chris
chris and ladybird i again i love the
[ __ ] difference in photos here yeah
we had the clown photos before and now
we've got this great
great job ashley great job do you know
in the there's pictures of those like
the giga chad picture
yeah the actual gigger chad yeah yeah
the cheat yeah you found out like
he that's a real person yeah yeah yeah
that's how i felt when i met like lady
beard
because that blew my mind when i thought
that was cg yeah everyone thought it was
ccg
and then and then what part of it was cg
no no no the uh
the uh the like the gigger chad meme oh
the keeper the jawline the jawline yeah
because
cg but it was a real dude yeah yeah
brothers and they all look like
yeah yeah and it's insanity and that's
what it felt like meeting ladybug yeah
he is the giga chat after all i mean i i
would hate how ladybeard wins
yeah on paper i don't think anyone can
argue with ladybird
being the biggest shot this isn't about
being like subjective like
objectively he's the biggest champion
otherwise it's a ladybug
like this it's the first time i've like
been in the presence of a chad i'm like
i know what it feels like to have your
energy sucked out and just
like taking everything just to be in the
presence that's really chatting
yeah yeah yeah all right i have a
feeling i know who won this
all right let's find out all right trash
days award to our biggest chad it goes
to the giga chat of the year yeah
goes to ladybird oh
well deserved well i want to know
who came last yeah that's what i want to
know so go go in order from first to
last
first ladybirds okay
[Applause]
what that's a [ __ ] lie what
wait 36 32 uh chris had 13.
that's 32. and then fourth place is gone
oh jerry i'm the least chad
what came in with 4.4
at least you're not the biggest clown
joey exactly it's all good that's still
a dog for me
it's chad i got biggest clown what's the
point anymore i thought there was going
to be like the dichotomy there
but no you couldn't beat the chat energy
from ladybird
you know it's it's it's impossible
because you're going to say look at this
this is like
this is like the final boss you see i
know i am blood of mere arm hair
compared to a ladybug this is just a
picture and i'm still sitting here
sweating man
like jesus things you don't want to see
at night
well-deserved put that on your cv this
guy slaps your woman on the ass what did
you do
thank you thank you thank you honestly